At this time, I'd like to welcome Director Marsha Murray
and Pat C. Jackson to give us the presentation
on Office of Business Opportunity budget.
Presentation. Good afternoon. Good afternoon.
Is my mic on? Yes, ma'am. Okay.
Good afternoon, mayor Pro TEM, Vice Chair and Council members,
I'm pleased to present OBO's proposed fiscal year 23
budget today. I'm joined today by OBO's Chief
Financial Officer Patsy Jackson. I'd also like to recognize
some of the OBO team members that are here today. Lala Morris
Obio's assistant director, as well as Pearl Cahalas,
our council liaison and Pio.
In his absence, I'd also like to acknowledge Tim Warren, who's our Certification
and Designation Division Manager, and two supervisors who
are overseeing our Contract Compliance Division at this point,
Shanita Petway, as well as Jamante Huey. I thank you
all for your fabulous work, your tremendous work in moving the core
services of the Office of Business Opportunity forward. Next slide,
please. At the Office of Business Opportunity,
we execute our mission of cultivating a competitive and diverse economic
environment and the City of Houston by promoting the success of small businesses
and developing Houston's workforce, with a special emphasis on historically
underutilized businesses and disenfranchised individuals
through the provision of several core services. Next slide, please.
This slide represents our organizational chart. Fund 1000
covers OBO's core services, including executive Oversight,
Certification, contract compliance, and External affairs and
workforce development. Accounting for our $5.4 million
budget and approximately 43 FTEs.
The Executive Leadership team includes myself, the Assistant
Director, our Chief Financial Officer, the Citywide Title VI
Compliance Coordinator and our one person analytics and
reporting team. Our Certification and Designation Division
administers six local certifications and two federal
certifications on behalf of the US. Department of Transportation.
Those certifications are listed here. In addition,
we facilitate historically underutilized business certification on
behalf of the State of Texas, and our newest certification
added to our directory is the Lgbtbe certification.
The Division also processes applications for the city's local preference
program. The Higher Houston First program, the Contract Compliance
Division, monitors all city contracts with the exception of housing and airport
contracts, to ensure compliance with the minority Women's Small
Business Enterprise program requirements and to enforce local and federal
labor standards, including prevailing wage compliance and prompt payment requirements
on city contracts. Our External Affairs team
raises awareness of OBO services and the city's contracting
opportunities and also provides local businesses with access to business development
resources. This team also administers business development
and capacity building programs. And finally, our Workforce Development
team facilitates initiatives such as the Turnaround Houston job in a Readiness
Fair. Next slide, please.
So this slide represents our Special Fund, Fund 24
24, which covers the Contractor Responsibility Fund,
which supports the administrative and programmatic operations of the city's.
Payer Play Program The Payer Play Program aims to
level the playing field for contracts between bidders that choose
to offer health benefits to their workforce and those who
do not. The program also offsets the cost of providing health care
to uninsured people in the Houston Harris County area.
The Contractor Responsibility Fund supports three city programs
and those programs are listed on this slide. Next slide,
please. So, in the interest
of time, I will ask you to review at your election slides
five and six, which provides more details about our core services.
I'll skip over to slide seven.
So, while we do have some flexibility in terms of
delivering OBS core services, there are statutory requirements
for components of our services at the local, state and federal levels.
Federal funding is tied to our Title Six certification and
contract compliance work. As it relates to certification,
federal regulations require that all recipients of Department of Transportation
funding in excess of $250,000 in
a federal fiscal year are required to have a Disadvantaged Business Enterprise
program to ensure nondiscrimination in the award and administration
of Department of Transportation assisted contracts.
Failure to properly administer the aforementioned programs can
result in a loss of Federal funding. Next slide,
please.
So, this slide we are describing the financial and societal impact
of our service deliveries. The services that OBO administers have
broad societal impact for not only small business owners, but also their employees.
Obio's contract compliance team advocates for and enforces
the rights of certified firms on contracts with goals, and ensures
that employees of City of Houston construction contractors are
paid appropriate wages, ultimately supporting the local economy
and improving the lives of Houstonians. Revenues collected
from the Paraplay program offset the cost of providing health care to uninsured
Houstonians. The City's Title Six program ensures
equal access to city facilities and program in by all
Houstonians. And our certification program serves to expand
opportunities for firms as they can be utilized on City of
Houston projects and on projects with other area agencies
and private companies. Some of those companies or
entities are listed at the bottom of this slide. Next slide,
please. And this slide
discusses the anticipated growth in number of customers that we
expect in fiscal year 23. We expect an increased
demand for MWSBE certification due to new
MWBE programs in the region, such as the Harris County
and Poor Houston race and gender conscious programs.
We also expect demands from businesses seeking to participate
in the Houston based NCWA Final Four Supplier
Diversity Initiative next year. And we also anticipate
that there will be additional opportunities for firms
brought on by infrastructure projects.
HPW has also predicted that there will
be an increase in the number of contracts that are
let. As a result, we anticipate an increase in our overall contract compliance
monitoring workload. And finally, the Northeast Water
Purification Plant Project has approximately 931
project 930 subcontractors participating
and growing. This project will increase our MWSBE
contract compliance monitoring and prevailing wage and labor standards monitoring.
Next slide, please. So at this time, I will ask
Ms. Jackson to discuss the projected revenues and expenditures in our
proposed FY 23 budget on our revenue
by funds. The General Fund revenue indicated on the first row
of this slide increased by 74% and FY
23 over FY 22. The special revenue on the second
row increased by 7.94%, and FY 23 over FY
22. Let's go to the next slide and give a little bit more information about
that. These are our revenue highlights. The FY
23 General Fund proposed budget increased by 74%
is due to the three additional FTEs transferring from the Houston
Public Works Department. This revenue consists of HPW's
contributions to support our contract compliance staff,
which currently funds nine positions. The General
Fund revenue supports the City's Payer Play program,
the FY 23 budget increased by 7.94%
and it is attributed to anticipated increases to the revenue that
supports Fund 24 24. Of note, though, Houston Public Works estimate
a 6% increase in revenue due to an increase of
vendors participating in the pay portion of the pay or
play program working on the new project. Houston Airport
System anticipate projects moving from design to construction phase,
and more contracts awarded using the pay option
will result in increased revenue, and the Housing and Community
Development Department anticipates more contracts in FY 23 which
will increase revenue by 15% to 20%.
Next slide, please.
Expenditure by Fund Obio's FY 22
General Fund estimate budget for Fund 1000 is 4.1 million.
The 5.4 million proposed budget for FY 23 reflected on
this slide shows a 32.58% increase due
to two additional position in OBO Solutions Center, which will manage
new business programs and increase the visibility of the Department
services. Three employees transfer from HPW
to the Contract Compliance Division to assist in managing the HPW contracts,
two additional positions for the certification division and a
onetime funding for vendor augmented contract monitoring to
ensure compliance with statutory requirements. The special
revenue expenditure line item reflects expenditures for
administrative and pragmatic operations of the City's payer
play program. This fund shows a 31.30%
decrease because the one time funding in FY 22 for ethan Houston
Fire Department personnel is not included in FY 23 budget.
In FY 23, this fund supports funding for health benefits,
pension contribution and municipal employees contractual
pay increases funded to maintain an electronic management system
to effectively track all pay or play activities. The FY
23 budget continues to support the contractor responsibility
funds initiatives such as the Client Access Program,
crisis called Diversion Program, and the Emergency Telehealth
and Navigation Ethan program. Next slide, please.
Why FY 23 personnel versus nonpersonal for Fund 1000
OBO's proposed budget of 5.4 million,
82% of that covers personnel expenses,
salaries and French benefits. Of the remaining
18% of our budget, 4% covers restricted
charge accounts that are charged backs by the City of Houston,
1% covers the cost of the B City Certification and
Contract Compliance Management system, and 13% covers
other services including the contract monitoring program,
the printing and reproduction, professional development and training
for our employees. Next slide please.
Slide 14, which is the FY 23 personnel versus nonpersonal
for fund 24. 24 covers the Contractor Responsibility Fund,
which supports the operations of the City of Houston payroll play program.
15% of that budget will fund personnel expenses
such as salaries, fringe benefits for the administrative responsible
for the financial and program oversight. The other 85%
of the budget will fund the three listed program and technology costs.
Next slide, please.
Slide 15 is our FY 23 budget expenditure net Change.
This slide is a visual representation of the net change
and general fund budget that we discussed earlier. Go to
the next slide, please. Slide 16
and 17. They both details what we discussed early in our
presentation. And that concludes our financial portion
of OBO's budget, and I will refer that back to our director. Thank you.
And thank you. And that concludes our presentation. Before I take questions,
I'd like to briefly highlight the appendix that follows, which you can
review at your election. The appendix provides additional information,
including Oba's organizational chart, a breakdown of staff
demographics, Obia's FY two accomplishments which
we're very proud of, and some of our unmet needs.
Thank you, Council Member
Ed Pollan. Thank you, Chair, and thank you,
Director, for your presentation and to your entire staff
for all the great work that you all do. I know you make the most
with a little, and it's appreciated and valued.
A couple of questions. We had a Disparity
study done, correct? We did. How much was that
Disparity study? Why are we not using that Disparity study?
And in the Disparity study, is it breaking down
opportunities based on specific race?
Okay, so we did commission a Disparity study that
will not be published. I'm sorry. Is it are
we good? Okay, so the city did commission a Disparity study,
and because there are concerns about the
methodology that was used to perform the Disparity study, the city
will not be publishing that study. So I cannot speak
about any of the substantive how long was that Disparity study covering?
What years did it cover? So it's covered twelve through 16
fiscal years, 1230 fiscal
years. Twelve through 16. And how much money did we spend on that?
It cost a little bit under a million dollars. And we're not
publishing it at all? No. And so now,
to my understanding, we are looking to do another Disparity study.
So there's currently an RFP that is
on the street soliciting proposals for
a new Disparity study covering fiscal years through
fiscal year 17, through fiscal year 21, a five year period,
and who makes a determination on whether the methodology was something
that we believe is useful or not.
So the determination is really based
on the experience with administering programs
like this, particularly the kind
of program that we have. Without going into
substantive details about what's contained within that
draft study. It really did not.
I believe in the memo that I wrote to the mayor that was shared with
council members. I believe I included in that memo that
it really did not reflect the way in which the
City of Houston administers its program. You put me back
in the queue. Thank you. Vice Mayor Pro TEM martha
Castex Tatum. Thank you, Director Murray. Thank you for your
presentation. I'm curious to know, last budget cycle,
we put forth a budget amendment for some additional dollars
to get caught up on our contract compliance.
Where are we in that process, and have we made any progress
with getting caught up on our contract compliance?
So I am happy to report that the mayor has, as part
of the fiscal year 22s budget, he's actually provided additional funding
for us to actually augment and our our existing contract
compliance monitoring services through the engagement of vendors. So additional information
will be provided shortly about that engagement,
because as is the case with other
departments, we're certainly not immune to the
great resignation. And so we have lost a
substantial number of our compliance officers,
which is why there has been this urgency to
actually augment our existing services. Unfortunately, we've only been
able to, and we're just having issues attracting compliance
officers. So we had seven compliance offers.
We're now up to two compliance officers. So really,
the rest of the remaining of the staff is really all hands on deck in
terms of trying to address the workload that currently exists.
What's the pay for a compliance officer? So,
for a compliance officer, it's approximately 48,000.
For a senior compliance officer, it's approximately 56,000,
and the qualifications for it. And so the compliance
officer requires a bachelor's degree and
one year experience, or years of experience can
be substituted year for year for the bachelor's degree. For a senior compliance
officer, the difference is two years experience.
Okay. Thank you, Council Member Ed Pollard.
Thank you, Chair. Sometimes when we
have contracts that come out, we're looking
for MWBEs to participate, but we
get word that there aren't any in the directory or there's a void for
minority vendors in that particular industry space.
Do we keep a log of where we may have voids
and try to find ways to identify minority companies within
the city that if we were to
reach out to them, could participate in certain contracts?
So we're not necessarily keeping a log, but we are aware
of some of the areas where there are
gaps. So when our external affairs team actually goes on
to the community, they may actually emphasize the
fact that there are opportunities in a particular area and
encourage for firms to get certified.
And we are generally just looking to increase the number
of firms and the variety, the diversity in terms of industry,
the diversity of firms that are actually certified.
And when it comes to the openings that you have,
so those are current openings that people can go online right now
and apply for those positions. Yeah. Any opening
that we have that has not been closed because we've
exhausted the period for which the posting is out absolutely are
available on the City's website. We do, actually, because we recognize
the challenges in reaching
out to people. So we have social media. My external affairs team has created
social media campaigns. We have leveraged our advisory
board members to actually reach out to their
network of folks to talk
about our various positions. We are perpetually talking
ad nauseam about these positions. And we've
also been just internally talking about reevaluating some of
the postings that we put out there. We certainly want to be clear about
what the responsibilities of the position, but we also want to talk about the benefits,
lead with the benefits of working for the city, lead with the benefits of the
impact. That the kind of work that you can do as a compliance officer can
have on the lives of people. But I think you all do a tremendous job
of putting out information. I'm always getting updates. I think we as
a council should collaborate more on making
sure our constituents have that information.
So whatever information you do have on current
openings, please send to my office. Sure. Thank you.
So just a quick follow up on Council Member Pollard's initial line
of questions on the Disparity study. So we
issued an RFP. We got it. We received the answers,
we paid them a million dollars. We received
the information, but we're doing nothing with it
at this point. It's not going to be published. We haven't paid the full amount
of the contract. What have we paid of the million dollars? I'm sorry?
What have we paid of the million whatever it was? Probably 900
and change. So we had $900,000 we paid for
Disparity study, and correct me if I'm
wrong. We define the scope because
we issued the RFP. So in an RFP, you define the scope of your
project. And if you define the scope of your project
as to, here are the particular questions. Here's the
information we want to look at. And they give us that.
And it has nothing to do with how we define the process,
then we shouldn't pay them a penny. If they did
follow it and gave us information that the data probably
came back and we didn't like it, then we should pay them
and we should release the data. And let us judge as to
was it effective or not, because I point back and I
say we had a process that we followed. We didn't identify
the scope. If they gave us the incorrect answers,
if we did identify the scope of the RFP and they
answered it based upon our scope check, if they didn't,
they shouldn't get a penny. So while I can't
delve into the substantive details of this, this is really a legal matter at this
point. I do want to say that it's not a matter of not liking the
final results. And certainly we do define
the scope. What we don't dictate is methodology. That actually
has to be something that's independently decided
by the consultant. It's a little bit more
nuanced and then taken into account the existing
programs that actually exist for us. But I'm
most comfortable deferring questions about the disparity study to our
legal department. Fine.
I understand. Pay for play. There's another
component that we include into the bid process that
awards points, and I forgot what it's called to companies
that are headquartered here in the city. Hire Houston first.
Hire Houston first. So Ed Pollard answers
the RFP and Dave Martin answers the RFP.
Ed Pollard. Pollard. I'm assuming the objective
of that is to get taxpaying dollars. More of an
opportunity to participate in our business. Ed Pollard
lives in the city. He works for his company here that's
based here. He has five employees. Dave Martin lives
in the City and Dave Martin has 600 employees that live
in the city of Houston. But yet he gets ten points
on a bid and I get zero. So if the objective
is to give opportunities to people, taxpayers,
then why do you look at that information and give him the
points? I've always had a big problem in our RFP process
with this because we have a number of companies
that are great companies in the city that employ a lot of
people that they lose bids on those ten
points, but yet they have an enormous employee
force that lives in the city, that are taxpayers and
derive a lot of benefit. But we give it to the small company
who has a third of those employees.
I know it was passed by council years ago, but why can't we
look at that? Because that fundamentally seems very unfair to me.
So I do want to say that hire Houston first. The designation which
my office administers is not based on size.
Really? The criteria is that headquarters? I'm sorry?
Headquarters. That's what it's based on, correct? It's what isn't it based on? Headquarters.
Sorry to interrupt. It's actually based on principal place of business.
We have headquarters as an option, or 20% of
their workforce is actually locally based, but it's not a size driven
designation. So the City has made a determination
that for those companies that have actually gone
through the designation process and are declared as a local business or
a city business, that if they're competitive,
there's a leg up in the bidding process.
So do you think that was it? Higher Houston First
is a fair and equitable program within the
confines of what we do, it is. But what we have found,
I will say that our local companies are actually very competitive.
So our analysis on an annual basis, we do publish a Higher
Houston First report, which we've been publishing for several
years, actually shows that our local companies are
securing contracts without the application of the Higher
Houston First designation. But it's there as
a safety net in the event. They're not competitive
on their own. For the investments, for the promoting the kind of
investments that you described earlier, isn't it a 10% variable?
I'm sorry? Isn't it a 10% on an RFP process? Isn't it a
10% equation?
Depending on the type of bid it is, I think it's like two to 3%
as long as you're within two to 3% of the lowest bid. Good.
So all my career, I've worked for a big firms that weren't
headquartered here. And we competed against really small firms,
and we had 600 people and they had five. And I always
felt that that was a very unfair deal to give
them the points, because sometimes we
may have lost business. I don't know. But I always thought if your
really objective is to give the opportunity to taxpayer citizens,
wow. Figure out how many you have that live here, pay taxes
here, and then compete against them and let the
numbers tell that story. But I'll get off my soapbox.
I'll be quiet over to Tiffany D.
Council Member Abby Cayman's office.
Good afternoon, Director. Mary. I have just one question
on behalf of Council Member Cayman. Due to the financial and budgetary constraints
the city continues to face from revenue limitations,
are there critical needs that your department are not able to address
at this time? And if there are, what are they? So, as I
mentioned earlier, we certainly struggling in
the contract compliance realm. And so the mayor is offering us
funding, us actually contracting out some of our
augmenting our existing contract compliance monitoring
services for a period of time.
We have performed analysis of how many people we do need
to perform contract compliance,
effective compliance, on a long term
basis. And the numbers are actually pretty high. And that's actually included
in the appendix. While we currently have
seven compliance officers, we are anticipating that
we need about 30 to 37 compliance officers.
We have been working with HPW,
and Ms. Jackson actually described
some transfers that have been made, personal transfers
from the HPW department to facilitate some of
our compliance functions. But at this point, we're not
certainly the help that we'll receive via vendors
will be great, but long term, we do need to
augment our increase our staffing.
Okay, Director Murray and Ms. Jackson, we have four public
speakers who are all in person here. And the first one we have
is Mr. Oliver, Jason Oliver.
He's the director of our Mic Communication Today and doing
a great job of it. I'll send you my invoice.
So management consulting has increased dramatically. I'm just trying to
figure out if that's where the contract compliance is showing up. Is that
what's happening there? The management consultant? Is that where we put this?
It's about 520? Yes. Okay. That's what I thought.
Okay. Just making sure you had talked about the 48,000
for the contract compliance. How does that compare to peer peer
roles? And then the third question
that I want to ask is about the crisis Call diversion funds
that were approved and allocated last year. I know that kind of falls under
your purview. Those are just now being put into use.
Can you talk about the delay in implementation there and kind of what
factors into that? Because it seems like the need for
those diversionary calls is significant, particularly during
the pandemic. Okay. Patsy, do you want to discuss
the crisis call diversion program was already being sponsored
through another source. We were just asked to
start to fund that source starting in 2021.
So it had already been funded before. It didn't just now start.
We just start to become a part of it.
So it's been affected before. Okay, so that
ARPA funding that's being used for that has been
actualized or it's not actually being used. I'm unclear
on what that means. So we're
not going to be poised to discuss any kind of ARPA funding
as it relates to that program as this fund focuses on the revenue
that's collected via the Pay option of Pay or play.
Got you. Okay. And as far as contract compliance,
the competitiveness of our
salaries, we have done ad hoc analyses
looking at other compliance officers in
the state, particularly Austin. And I know that our assistant director
just came back from a conference where she
spoke with other practitioners compliance
contract compliance practitioners and certainly discovered that our
salaries are not, in fact, competitive.
Surprise, surprise. Thank you. Thank you,
Sarah. Blanding. Blanding. I'm sorry.
Hey, thank you so much for all you do with so
little. And I'm just going to keep
talking about these compliance specialists because I've been obsessed with them since you
all did your presentation last year. I couldn't believe how many
we needed versus what you all actually had to operate with.
And I appreciate that there's been an effort for some sort of stop
gap in the meantime,
and I appreciate to know that the salaries
are not competitive. Unfortunately, I'm not surprised.
I guess my question is, what do you need in order to expand
to the adequate number of compliance specialists to address our city's
needs? I'm just concerned there has not been a strong
effort to address it. And I guess that's honestly a side comment to the City
Council, and I'd love to see some budget amendments.
So I'm just curious what you all need, like what that dollar amount would be
to actually get that 30 to 37 in a competitive
salary.
Ideally, we would have all senior Business Development Coordinators,
because I would say that the level of work really rises to a
senior compliance level on a daily basis.
And I'm not really fantastic at multiplication,
so I'd say $58 to $60,000
times the number of persons
that are actually needed, the 30 to 37.
All right, thank you. Adding to the two that
we already have, that's 2.1 million. Just if anyone wants to write that down,
got it. Thank you. Council Member Ed Pollard. Thank you,
Chair. The county recently did a Disparity study,
did they not? They did. It was published, I think, maybe about a little
bit over a year, a year and a half ago. Do you know the firm
that they used to do their Disparity study?
Do I know the firm? Are you familiar with the firm? I am.
Is it the same firm that we used? It is. Okay.
And so we use the same
firm as them. They publish theirs. We're not publishing ours.
But we spent almost a million dollars.
My issue with it is we keep talking about
we have budget restraints or we don't
have the money to pay for employees or whatever the case may be
across the board. But then we have a vendor who answered
the solicitation. We paid them almost a million dollars, but we're not
going to release the report when the county used
the same vendor for their report,
which actually highlighted a lot of the deficiencies that they had in their
program. I don't even think they had a program. Right. So I
do think while, again, I don't want to get into
the details of necessarily the issue
here, I do think it's important to note that the county
did not have a program. So you're starting with a clean slate.
And so the analysis of a nonexisting program and
contracting patterns versus a program that's actually been around since 1984
and the nuances of such a program is
material to how our Disparity studies actually conducted.
Thank you. So, Vice Chair legal's budget presentation is
Thursday at 01:00. And guess who will be sitting in the captain's chair?
You. So ask that question on Thursday.
Ms. Joe Groch.
Grochell did? Good the first time, bad the
second. My apologies. How are you? Apology accepted.
Thank you, ladies. So I understand your mission
is to convulse to cultivate a competitive and diverse
economic environment.
My question to you is, with $1.7 trillion
in college debt and many people questioning the value of a college degree,
are efforts being made to eliminate college from many
job requirements by promoting skills for, quote,
unquote, new collar jobs? So we're not
specifically engaged in efforts to eliminate college. Our workforce development
team is actually focused on just
providing information about different
career pathways for Houstonians. Okay,
thank you. Okay. Thank you,
Mr. Butler.
Good afternoon, Director. I want
to talk about what could be compared to what you've guys been talking about,
of what is that will sort itself out. But I'm from northeast
Houston, and in my opinion, business creation has been lacking
for where I reside. So thus it's the number one issue
for me and the residents where I live. So I'm curious if
there is any possibility going forward in
an evolution not this budget,
next budget, but there are three things that I was wondering
if you could say, I see it in the stars or.
No, we're not structurally able to do it. The first
one is to launch a business incubator or accelerator in
conjunction with the HCC North Forest campus
that exists in my community. Also to create an
Office of Research and Evaluation charge with studying barriers
to wealth and business development in communities of color.
Lastly, establish an Office of Advocacy and
Intergovernmental Affairs to score the
effects of proposed legislation and regulations on
barriers to minority owned small business creation and success.
So for the last, establishing the Office
of Advocacy, that is definitely not something that I
can commit to. But I think for all three, what I can say to you
is that we welcome partnerships
to explore these areas that you've
actually pointed out, to see how we on our own with
our existing resources. I don't think this is something necessarily that we
can do all three, but I think in partnership with others, we can actually
support some of the objectives of those three items that
you just listed. Right. It was a conversation about growing into
oneself compared to being that tomorrow.
Understood. Thank you. Okay, thank you. And thank
you, Director Murray. And Ms. Jackson. Appreciate your insight. Thank you.
Thank you.